avec vous François Noël buffet bonsoirir
vous êtes le président LR de la
commission des Lois du Sénat un mot
c'était attendu peu suspense la première
étape est passée pour ce texte issu de
la CMP oui incontestablement il y avait
pas de d'inquiétude pour le vote de ses
conclusions devant le Sénat puisque nous
avions déjà voté largement le texte que
celui qui sort de la commission mix
paritaire est à 90 % le nôtre al quand
je dis le nôtre c'est celui de la
majorité sénatoriale naturellement
adopté le 14 novembre dernier adopté le
14emb é d'abord ici au Sénat donc c'est
une étape de plus nous attendons
maintenant que l'Assemblée nationale se
prononce pour qu'enfin ce texte puisse
trouver sa promulgation et son
évidemment sa mise en place on a vu
Gérald Darmanin à l'instant dans
l'extrait répondre au fait que le RN
allait voter ce projet de loi
immigration parce que aussi Marine Le
Pen appelle à voter ce texte qui ressort
de la CMP elle a dit tout à l'heure à
l'Assemblée nationale on peut se réjouir
d'une victoire idéologique du
rassemblement national et effectivement
elle a parlé notamment de la priorité
nationale qui rentre dans la loi
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de de ce
qui se joue autour du fait que le RN se
rallie à ce texte le rassemblement
national Madame Le Pen tente à holdup
euh il ne faut pas qu'elle le réussisse
ils n'ont absolument rien fait dans ce
texte ça n'est pas leur texte mais ils
essayent d'en récupérer les fruits euh
chaque fois qu'il y a eu des textes
importants sur les sujets régaliens
elle n'a pas franchi l'obstacle donc là
il se trouve qu'après avoir critiqué ce
texte pendant de nombreux mois de
nombreuses semaines et avoir dit pique
pendre euh elle vient au secours de la
victoire c'est juste le signe d'une
grande faiblesse de mon point de vue et
cet argument sur le fond la priorité
nationale qui rentrerait dans la loi
c'est absolument faux c'est absolument
faux il suffit des allocations par
exemple qui ne seront pas verersé de la
même façon à des étrangers et à des
citoyens français ça fait pas une
priorité nation pas ça du tout on a
conditionner un certain nombre de
prestations qui sont non contributives
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres mais
dans le reste du texte il faut bien
regarder que la question est au
contraire de mieux traiter les migrants
qui viennent sur le territoire et de ne
pas et de pouvoir se donner les
conditions de cette intégration dans les
les les meilleurs c'est ça l'enjeu faut
pas raconter l'histoire et puis c'est le
fait de dire la France choisit sa
politique migratoire don actcte mais
tous les pays du monde le font nous ne
le faisions pas jusqu'à maintenant nous
allons le faire mais en aucun cas il
s'agit de privilégier les uns pour les
autres il s'agit simplement de fixer des
conditions et quand on est sur le
territoire national et qu'on respecte à
la fois les de la République et qu'on se
comporte très très bien on fait partie
de la communauté nationale avec grand
plaisir dans ce cadre comment comprendre
cette hésitation de la part de députés
Renaissance ou mod qui hésite à voter le
texte sorti par la CMP c'est ce qu'on va
voir dans une heure 10 à l'Assemblée
nationale notamment votre et bien
équivalent à l'Assemblée nationale Sacha
aliier qui est le président de la
commission des lois et qui est
Renaissance qui a dit vouloir voter
contre mais il faut qu'il se ressaisisse
ce texte est aussi le leur c'est celui
de leur majorité c'est celui que nous
avons construit avec eux pendant la
discussion sur cette CMP donc il faut
pas qu'il se laisse impressionner par la
tentative de holdup de Madame Le Pen
assumons notre travail assumons notre
vision portonsla mais nous ne ne nous
comportons pas en fonction de ce que dit
ce que fait ou ce que ne fait pas Madame
Le Pen c'est le seul moyen de s'en
sortir peut-être que ces députés
voulaient cet article 3 qui s'est
transformé en article 4 bis avec des
revaloris avec des régularisation de
travailleurs sans papier dans des
métiers en tension on comprend avec
l'article qui sort de la CMP il y a pas
grandchose qui change au contraire c'est
même peut-être plus compliqué encore
pour une personne qui va demander un
titre de séjour dans ses métiers
enention non alors je suis en désaccord
c'est pas plus compliqué je trouve que
la procédure est simple elle permet
simplement à l'état de contrôler la
réalité du travail et de préserver de
préserver à la fois la personne qui
demande la régularisation et de
préserver en même temps et de vérifier
que l'employeur n'est pas un employeur
voyou voilà c'est quand même intéressant
sur le fond et ça ne ferme aucune porte
à personne j'ai une dernière question
comment est-ce qu'on comprend cette
réunion à l'Élysée avec les chefs de fil
de la majorité et les ministres
concernés vous y voyez une crise vous au
sein de la macronie mais il est pas
normal quand vous avez des responsables
de votre partie politique qui laisse
entendre qu'il pas qu'ils ne vont pas
voter un texte à l'heure qu'ils ont
travaillé dessus que le Président de la
République et la première ministre essae
de trouver des explication essaie de
remettre un peu d'ordre et je veux dire
ça me scandalise pas je trouve ça plutôt
normal et bien merci merci François Noël
buffet pour cette réponse au micro de
public
S